live in Moscow the German electro
pioneers craft vac recently played to
6,000 fans a sold-out gig inside the
state Kremlin Palace their show boasted
elaborate 3d projections but as usual a
static performance from the artists
themselves what did the audience make of
their performance and what do Russians
think of craft work in general don't
communicate with their audiences like
rock musicians who throw drumsticks into
the crowd or shout things to rouse the
audience when kappa perform it's like a
monologue and yes there that system
analog this is the state Kremlin Palace
moments before the concert the room
slowly started to fill up and fans put
on their 3d glasses
Kraftwerk have just won a Grammy Award
in the US but is that important to the
band
yet the most supreme agree I don't think
winning a Grammy means much the calf ech
of course it's not a bad at all but for
a frog that's not what counts anymore
bigger than a gram what perhaps does
strike a chord with Russians is craft
wax allusions to an overbearing stencil
like in the song computer world Russia's
presidential elections are due in
mid-march the band from Dusseldorf has a
history of addressing political and
social issues in their
characteristically unemotional style not
to everyone's liking when your cuts are
too cold to conceptual they don't show
any romantic feelings Russians love that
gives a sense of harmony afterwards
stop burning [ __ ] tomorrow morning they
played 17 tracks from various stages of
their 5 decade-long career most fans
were thrilled by the moisture it was a
powerful show the material was once
really innovative only fans who know how
everything started will truly appreciate
their music who the study especially the
3d show was great and the music was
excellent
we didn't regret coming I'm orchards
really enjoy coming here listening to
their music it's great they performed
here while sugar that the craft beer I
like the Beatles of electronic music the
gig was a big event I doubt they'll play
here again so I'm happy we came global
proceed
with this really craft wax last Moscow
gig they seem to have plenty of fans in
Russia to welcome them back
you
[Applause]